[Music]
on a regular day in los angeles eve and
her children izzy and josh are stuck in
traffic as they engage in lively
conversations something strange happens
nearby many cars sink into the ground
from what eve can see from her seat they
soon realize the ground beneath them is
breaking forming a sinkhole when the
family tries to run away the cracks
almost catch up with them josh stops to
help a little girl but cannot keep up
with his family after that he eventually
falls into the hole followed by his
mother seconds before going down eve
tells her daughter that she loves her an
aerial view of the city shows us an
enormous hole in the middle of it people
go into a frenzy and a state of
emergency is declared somewhere else
eve's husband gavin is in a meeting with
his employer he is a former military
pilot who left his job following a crash
it caused him to suffer mental trauma
which led to hallucinations and manic
episodes gavin sees the news about the
sinkhole and runs to the site to look
for his family finally seeing a familiar
face izzy hugs him and cries in his arms
gavin's heart drops upon finding out
that his wife and son are no more
suddenly a flock of strange birds flies
outside from the sinkhole and caw at the
crowd before disappearing into the sky
morbius was that you in the following
scene we see eve waking up in a field
confused she looks around and notices a
green light in the sky she is near a
stone with a bloodied handprint on it
then she remembers the flashes of josh
falling into the hole and starts looking
for him after crossing a meadow she
reaches the woods and comes across a man
who is just as confused as her both of
them notice smoke rising nearby and run
to check what it is to their surprise
every person and vehicle that fell into
the sinkhole has landed here eve
reunites with her son and the other
survivors they shortly find out that
they fell from the green ripple in the
sky but no one knows a way to go back up
the group is led by dr sam who asks
everyone to make the best out of the
situation by collecting food and water
everyone does their part for the group
except for a police officer named mary
beth who tries to hide a box of protein
bars when josh calls her out she claims
that they cannot stay as a community
when tough times arrive all of a sudden
a wolf comes into their sight and
attacks them i hope it kills mary beth
soon the animal is followed by its pack
sending the survivors into chaos
everyone gets inside the closest cars
but eve is stuck between two wolves a
man named ty shoots the animal dead and
saves her life however the bullet also
hits josh and hurts him severely he is
brought into a bus where sam tries his
best to save his life a while later he
and eve set off to look for an ambulance
that also fell into the hole earlier in
their absence sam's daughter riley takes
care of josh back in la the chief
scientist of the department of homeland
security dr sophia is delivering an
official statement to the public she
claims that no person who fell into the
hole has any chance of survival but they
are doing their best to retrieve the
bodies after listening to her speech
gavin gets a strange vision where he
sees eve near the rock with the
handprint he tells izzy that he has been
getting these visions since his accident
but he has always only seen empty fields
and meadows this time the vision is
strange because he is seeing his family
in the same place that has haunted him
for so long meanwhile sophia's team
sends a drone into the sinkhole but as
it gets closer to the green light it
stops sending signals outside gavin gets
another vision and sees the crashed
drone this time his ptsd is giving him
sinkhole vision he tries telling sophia
about his visions but she dismisses him
as just another morning family member
not just her but izzy also thinks the
same gavin realizes that his claims
sound insane but if there is a chance
his wife and son are alive he will do
anything to save them he rushes home and
looks for pictures he and eve took on a
trip because he remembers seeing this
stone with the print in real life to his
surprise he finds the picture and finds
out the address where the stone is
somewhere else even sam are still
looking for the ambulance when they find
tai about to commit the unthinkable eve
stops him insisting that he deserves to
live no matter what he has been through
ty joins them on the search because he
saw the ambulance when he first landed
back in la gavin finds the rock and
starts digging around it to look for
more clues as he thinks his father has
gone insane until he finds eve's ring on
the ground that she used to wear around
her neck then even the group finally
find the ambulance in an empty field she
notices the hollywood hill sign on the
vehicle and the hill in front of them
the two look identical which means they
are still in la but in the past when
humans are yet to discover it suddenly
they are attacked by a tiger who chases
them off the track sam falls down a hill
but the other two cannot look for him
while being chased by the beast of an
animal at one point they are seconds
away from being attacked before the
tiger falls into a trap it is clearly
made by a man which means they are not
the only people here for the next few
hours they look for sam and find him
lying at the bottom of the hill his back
is injured but he is still conscious
they immediately have to get back to the
camp because by now josh's wound has
become infected when sam realizes that
he is slowing the group he asks the
others to get to josh first eve leaves
ty to take care of the man while she
returns to the camp on her own meanwhile
mary beth finds a car with drugs inside
the trunk and seems to know who it
belongs to she starts asking people
about a guy with a green jacket while at
it she meets a girl named veronica and
her mute sister lily veronica's father
died in the attack yesterday and his
body was dragged away by the animals she
leaves mary beth to look after her
sister before going into the woods to
look for her father alongside a man
named scott while on the mission scott
finds out veronica is extremely
religious and thinks that if they are
lost god will help them soon eve arrives
at the camp and gives her son an
antibiotic his wound is also sewn and
his temperature starts to stabilize in
the meantime gavin watches a doctor
talking about the sinkhole on tv since
sophie didn't take him seriously gavin
decides to meet the doctor to ask for
help initially the doctor is skeptical
but he agrees to carbon date the ring
gavin found somewhere else sophie finds
out about gavin's plan and calls him to
the base three years ago a similar
sinkhole was formed in the desert and on
the same day around the same area
gavin's accident took place the results
of the carbon dating come out and the
ring is said to be from 10 000 bc
because of all the evidence sophie
believes gavin and starts devising a
rescue plan she introduces him to a
special airplane that they have designed
to send into the sinkhole gavin will not
be allowed to pilot it but his close
friend levi is called for the job back
in 10000 bc veronica and scott come
across a bunch of camels about to walk
into a tar pit scott stops them and
saves their lives at the same time they
see veronica's father's corpse in the
middle of a palm symbol made of stones
in the woods sam and ty meet a man named
lucas when they reach the camp we find
out that lucas is mary beth's son and a
drug dealer they're not on good terms
but mary beth is protective of him riley
takes care of sam and his back injury
alongside scott they use the drugs they
found in one of the cars as an
anesthetic when scott returns he tells
everyone that they're in 10000 bc he is
an anthropology graduate who knows that
eight camel remains were rescued from
tar pits a month ago those were the same
eight camels he saved earlier yeah that
checks out and doesn't sound like
[ __ ] at all lucas refuses to believe
him and sets out on his own journey to
look for a way out mary beth follows him
and the two eventually reach a trap that
was definitely made by a human meanwhile
eve and tai also set off to search for
food but while hunting they come across
a bear it chases them into the cave
where their life is saved however the
opening to the cave is blocked by stones
and they're stuck inside suddenly lucas
and mary beth appear behind them having
entered the cave to look for the native
person they explore the place and
eventually come across a water body ty
goes in to check for a way out but comes
across a bigger surprise everyone
follows him into the water and come out
the other side to a years old corpse it
is clear that the man was from the
future like them and lived in isolation
he committed the unthinkable with a gun
that is lying to his side the group
decides to keep this a secret from the
rest of the survivors not wanting to
destroy their spirit they also find
edible mushrooms outside party time by
the end of the day they return to the
camp with food for everyone while
enjoying them tai tells eve that he has
a brain tumor and doesn't have long to
live he had given up hope but the
sinkhole has given him a purpose in life
now that everyone is going to die in the
future levi and gavin discuss the
mission as levi gets ready for it before
leaving he confesses to having an affair
with eve long ago and the two separate
on a bad note i'm off to save your
daughter by the way the flight takes off
as the mission control holds its breath
however before reaching the green light
they lose connection and the plane
crashes in the past gavin and dizzy hug
each other assuming that they have lost
levi as well in the camp riley thanks
scott because he used the drugs found in
the car to help her father earlier scott
takes the compliment before revealing
that he buried them somewhere in the
forest and doesn't remember where
suddenly the green light grows bigger
and the aircraft with levi enters the
atmosphere in the morning lucas eve josh
scott and riley set off to look for the
aircraft they eventually come across
levi he reunites with eve before telling
them about his mission the group is
happy that people back home are doing
something to help them after that the
group looks for the crashed airplane
that might still be functioning after a
few minutes of walking they reach the
crash site and find the plane with the
radio and engine compressor broken if
they can find the right parts levi might
be able to fix it but it seems
impossible to get the parts in this age
instead they collect food supplies that
he brought deciding to return to the
camp to their surprise the airplane
receives a signal from three miles away
in the woods it might be the only way
for them to get out so they decide to
follow it meanwhile in the camp lily is
being pressured by her sister veronica
to refrain from talking to anyone
frustrated she runs to the woods and
comes across something horrific when
everyone gathers around a while later
they discover the dead body of a man who
is one of them lily knows what happens
to him but veronica doesn't let her talk
to anyone tai who is also a psychiatrist
makes it his mission to help the little
girl back in the present la is hit by an
earthquake it doesn't do much harm but
the cause is declared to be levi's
airplane crash because of this any
further rescue mission is halted gavin
goes to sophia's office to retaliate but
finds out that she is on a holiday
instead he finds a picture of her with a
woman named rebecca who was also a part
of the other sinkhole exploration
program he assumes that she has answers
to his questions and finds her address
on the internet after that he and izzy
drive to meet rebecca the following
morning they reach rebecca's home and
find her with sophie they reveal that
when the last sinkhole appeared in a
desert a group of scientists was sent
inside to explore it however the green
rift closed before they could come out
which trapped them in 10 000 bc for the
past three years the group that was
trapped consisted of people close to
sophie and rebecca so they are adamant
about continuing the rescue mission even
though the high command is against it
rebecca has built an aircraft in secrecy
that will help them enter the sinkhole
again it has modifications that won't
cause an earthquake either damn that's
some good science however they will have
to launch it in secret and it will have
to be piloted by gavin in the camp ty
sits lily down and asks her questions
about what she saw yesterday veronica
insists that she cannot speak but lily
proves her wrong by saying that she saw
an old man where the dead body was found
as she tells them this the settled man
is watching them from the woods
somewhere else lucas finds out that his
stash of drugs was hidden by scott and
follows him everywhere since the drugs
were worth a lot the group eventually
reaches a fort like place clearly built
by a civilization scott assumes that it
is an indigenous civilization of the
past the place is also the location
where the signal is coming from they
enter the fort and separate into groups
of two to look for the source josh and
riley end up in a room with a secret
door that leads them outside the fort
meanwhile eve and levi go to a strange
building where a dead body lies inside
of a palm-shaped mark made with stones
levi reveals that his mission was also
to find the scientists who disappeared
three years ago and the dead man is one
of them at the same time lucas and scott
get into an argument when lucas finds
out scott lost his stash suddenly they
are attacked by a native of the fort who
knocks them both out outside josh and
riley are also spotted and chased down
the hills they hide in between the rocks
and somehow manage to save their lives
then the natives go after levi and eve
while trying to run away they end up in
a room filled with children one little
guy asks them to hide and sends the
guards away when they come looking for
the trespassers scott and lucas wake up
next to the dead body from earlier they
use a lighter to free their hands and
run outside by now josh and riley have
also returned to get the rest of the
survivors they gather up out of the
native site with the help of a kid he
shows them the way out even though the
leader of the tribe is his grandfather
before everyone can escape they are
found and are about to be killed until a
woman stops the people in the end the
group escapes and goes back to the camp
scott is in shock because he heard the
tribe speak english but the europeans
aren't supposed to come to the land
until decades later in the following
scene levi and the group reached the
camp and tell the others about
everything that happened when it gets
dark pie notices lily sitting alone and
approaches her he wins her trust before
asking her if she is hiding something
lily reveals that veronica is not her
sister a year ago she was kidnapped by
veronica and her father and has been
with them ever since ty is shocked at
the revelation when veronica arrives
with the food she senses that he knows
the truth and runs away meanwhile in the
future rebecca brings gavin to an
ancient civilization which is assumed to
be where the survivors of the sinkhole
ended up this is proven when they find
an ancient letter from eve apologizing
to gavin for not believing his
hallucinations gavin is also told that
he has to pilot the plane into the
sinkhole today or else it will close the
next evening and the others will remain
trapped in the past seriously where is
the science coming from in this show
there is a chance that he will never
return but izzy allows him to go
regardless
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching